[Music]
on today's show we talked to a young man
who recently became a single father of
three young girls
we also talked to a mom who's sitting
her daughter who has anxiety off to
college and we talked to a woman who
wonders if i never had adversity as a
kid what am i gonna do when i face it as
an adult stay tuned
[Music]
yo yo what's up this is john with the dr
john delony's show
we were shooting the intro again because
i screwed it up last time but listen
[Music]
i'm going to talk nicely to myself about
it i'm going to say hey um james wrote
me some notes here on the show intro and
i didn't read them but i'm gonna be
better about it next time
and um
i'm gonna be like a goldfish with with
their little their little memories as
they say in whatever simon cynic book i
don't know who writes that something
like that but i'm so glad you're with us
hey
i was just looking at the show data and
the numbers is continue to just grow and
grow grow whether you're watching us on
youtube whether you are downloading this
and just listening to it on podcast
i am
so grateful so grateful that you're in
our gang pass this along to your friends
your buddies people that you don't like
whoever you think would benefit from
listening show i i'm just it's
like i wish i had the words for it it's
humbling it sounds like a trite silly
thing i'm so grateful that um y'all are
in our gang and we're always looking for
more folks in the gang so
i am truly truly grateful um let's go
straight to the calls today let's go to
samuel in h-town where i'm from what's
up samuel
samuel you there
uh can you hear me there you are what's
up man
i'm doing well bless you i i've i've
heard you since your very first show you
ever aired really
yeah and i i'm telling i don't know if
it's because you're from houston but you
are just i mean you're so something
about your manner and the way you speak
is so familiar and it's just a piece of
home and it's
listen if you want ever thought i think
i might want to go to houston but every
time i hear delony speak i want to put a
screwdriver in my ear you probably don't
want to move to houston because
i'm speaking for on behalf of the city
maybe no man thank you so much brother
it's good to talk to you and uh what's
up man how can i help
well i'm uh 30 i'll be 32 this year um i
uh
this last year i
have found
myself to be a single father to my three
kids ages two four and six
um i'm the exclusive parent their mom
hardly ever sees them and uh
i
lost my job two months ago
um
and so here i am uh the life i've built
was built around certain realities like
like you know a stable family and and a
certain trajectory and that really has
all come to a
screeching halt i've looked back over
the last 10 years
to just it's my if i'm being honest my
last 10 years is just i feel like i've
been putting out
fires just turn around and find a bigger
one and i'm coming to a point i'm
reaching a point where um i mean i have
good days and bad days and today i'm
okay but i feel like i'm always
this close just not giving a rip i don't
i barely even know how anymore um i'm
just i'm losing the impetus to even care
i don't know how to explain it and i
don't know what i'm gonna do next i
don't see what my future's supposed to
be yeah and i i yeah
yeah
man so just brother brother i'm sitting
with you and i'm sorry i get i got
there's not a like a
cool saying that you know you'd cross
stitch and put on a bathroom wall or
something that's gonna make this feel
better and i'm sorry you know what i
mean sorry what happened to your
marriage man
you've been putting out fires for a
decade what happened
well i i i mean we our relationship was
really really toxic from the very very
beginning um that's not that's not even
remotely an exaggeration
and uh i thought i could save someone i
thought i could you know fix somebody
and she probably she probably thought
somewhat the same thing and we were we
were both toxic enough to you know
continue to spiral um i guess i guess we
felt we could both handle each other's
toxicity because we could both tear each
other apart and
kiss and make up in the next five
seconds and tear each other apart again
yeah and uh i think that cycle just
reached ah i mean we both made awful
decisions throughout that marriage and i
think it reached ahead for her
what does that mean
y'all both cheated on each other
yeah okay
uh was your addiction involved
i think i i've i've been you know i
don't like to admit it i i've had a porn
addiction for 10 years yeah okay all
right
so why is mom not involved in her kids
lives
well she sees them every other weekend
and she's very happy with that
arrangement um she she's never i i've
been the one taking care of them even
when we were married for the most part
um
she that's just
it's hard to explain i mean i don't it's
hard to explain she she's happy she's
happy to kind of be the holiday mom and
take him to the beach and then bring him
back and
so what happened at work brother
it was a really really really toxic uh
work environment i i
i worked for i've worked for the
catholic church for ten years
ah there you go and it just kind of just
got real i i maybe i shouldn't put it
that way but it just got really really
awful and toxic and
uh you know things were really really
mismanaged it was just awful management
and it just got from bad to worse and
eventually i was i was a church musician
okay i've been a true musician for
forever okay
you know so how are you how are you
feeding you and the babies right now
well i
i'm i'm i've took out a personal loan
and i'm uh which i know is not smart and
uh by next month that's not gonna work
and uh i live in friendswood we're gonna
have to move to be near my family in
spring okay um
and uh which for those listening is from
you're in
very south houston and you're gonna have
to move way north houston
um yeah
we're starting from the ground up yeah
um
man
so
a lot of you mentioned you're you're a
fixer you like to take care of other
people
um
you've got a history of infidelity
you've got a porn addiction
all those things point back to a history
of
someone who doesn't like who they see in
the mirror where did you learn that
where did you learn that you suck
i i
my
my parents um
fought like cats and dogs growing up
that was just normal i mean you know
three times a week just absolute
hysteria fits we were part of a
very very
rigid crazy religious cult for 10 years
growing up from about age 10 to 19 where
everything about you was just wrong and
evil and twisted um and so going into
adulthood i really believed everything
about human beings was just messed up
and wrong
i never fit in with anything i i
i couldn't just make normal friends or
have normal relationships um i never
just i never could get a i mean i
couldn't even get a girlfriend it was
awful it was really bad and then you
finally got one and you thought
well you have a model for what marriage
looked like man right yeah and he had a
model for it which was let's have these
caustic wars
and then let's um
stick it out and figure it out and let's
keep making humans while we're having
these caustic wars that's the only
picture you had here's what i'm getting
at um
if you and i were just having a drink
hanging out downtown houston somewhere
off kirby and we're just hanging out
i would look at you and be like dude you
made some stupid decisions and i would
smile at you right and you have and
your pictures for what life is
is so jacked up
and you have a body
a little kid who is still trying to
still wondering what they're doing to
make mom and dad so upset
still wondering what is it about me that
god hates so much
and that
ultimately becomes the root of
i can't be in the same room with my wife
i've got these three little kids that
i'm thinking about cashing out on
that a cheap um
a cheap fake fantasy on my cell phone
with
you know whatever
all of that points back to
man why do my parents hate me like what
what about me as a six-year-old right
all that you've been carrying that crap
around forever
yeah and you chase it and you chase and
you chase it and now you found yourself
here man like
man
it caught up with you
and so here we are right and so now
i'll tell you this so back in grad
school um my professor
was one of the most astute assignments i
was ever given i challenge anybody
listening to this to do this
said i don't want you to write
like a mission statement because if
you're in this doctoral program you can
you can navigate words well you can
write something pretty and fancy and
poetic and whatever
i want you to draw a picture with like
matte pencils and crayons draw a picture
of your personal mission
and i'd never considered that and i sat
down
with like i got some of my kids stuff
out and i drew it
and you know what the picture came like
that just came to me as i'm drawing and
again i'm a terrible artist like
comically so i look like i've got some
major like cognitive dysfunctions when i
try to draw a picture but the picture
ultimately was
a big fire
probably a neighborhood or a city or
something and then a curb
and then me sitting on the curb next to
somebody extending a lighter
well they've got a cigarette
and so i want you to picture me and you
right now we're just sitting on a curb
and everything behind you is on fire
and i'm handing you a light
and
now we're going to try to figure out
what comes next
is that cool
yeah um so for some reason or another
i'm
shaking a lot just
having i don't know
just hearing it but yeah okay
so here's a couple of things that i'm
gonna tell you to set the context for
what comes next
um first of all your body is
chemically addicted to stress to
cortisol adrenaline and beyond it has
been your entire life
and at some point those things those
chemicals think of them like drano right
they'll keep cleaning you've heard me
say this before on the show they'll
clean a hair clog out of your pipes once
a year right you can get away with it if
you wake up every day and dump drano in
your pipes eventually it's going to eat
through the pipes
right and it's going to melt everything
that's where you're at
so number one you're going to have to
make some decisions to detox from stress
from the chemicals that surge through
your body my guess is if there's not
chaos in your life you will make it
just so your body gets its hit is that
is that fair am i am i right
probably if work is going good you'll
come up with some some theological thing
or some something that the catholic
church did in ireland that you need to
have a fight about at work is that you
yeah okay and if something else if
that's not in the cards then you're
pissed off if they didn't get you the
right chords for your guitar what am i
right
okay
but yeah if your marriage is okay
you're going to text that woman back
you know what i mean yep things are okay
i'm gonna i'm gonna text her back and
it's all cool it's just cool and then
she's like can i send a picture and
you're like your heart starts beating
fast and for one second you feel alive
and you say yes
yes am i right
yep okay
you have to commit for the sake of you
and those little girls
that i'm going to detox off stress which
means i'm going to have to learn to live
in peace
and you've never had that this is new
you don't even have a picture of what
that looks like let me paint it for you
imagine getting home from a job that you
mostly like nobody likes everything at
work i'm i live in a cartoon and i don't
like everything about my job
you'll get home
and you will play with your daughters
and you'll get onto one of them about
math and you'll tell one of them to pick
up her clothes and one of them's gonna
have a conversation with you about a
period and you're gonna be like what i
what you're gonna do all that
and then you're gonna watch some dumb
show and you're gonna read a book and
then you're gonna do you're just gonna
go the hell to sleep you're gonna go to
sleep
can you even imagine
and then you're gonna wake up and you're
gonna have some crappy garage gym
because you can't leave because you've
got three kids and you're a single dad
and you're gonna go work out the next
morning right so that's what i'm
and you're gonna laugh and you're gonna
get a babysitter or mom's gonna pick up
you're gonna go grab a drink with some
buddies this i'm painting you a picture
of what this can look like
number two you're addicted to outburst
to these loud
demonstrative moments because you keep
everything so crashed inside of you
and hear me say this from this point
forward
yelling is trauma for a child
never yell again
got it
i don't know how but i mean i hear you
here's how never yell again
okay
you promise
i
i don't know yes you can here's what you
do today you're gonna take your
six-year-old and your four-year-old and
you're gonna sit him down and you're
gonna say daddy's gonna start talking
differently in this house and i've
scared you guys and i have yelled and me
and your mommy yelled and i will never
yell again
and now it's game on
and when you find yourself yelling you
will stop
and you'll say i'm so sorry who taught
you to yell your mom and dad
oh my god yeah okay
all the time so when i say yelling is
trauma you know that to be true
yeah
okay so we're never gonna yell again
number three what have you done to look
for a job
mostly looked at what i'm
what is out there and it's
pretty slim slim pickings i mean it's i
mean if you're a 20 year old in college
it's awesome but
you know if you have time to work all
day 50 an hour but i i'll have to change
i i i'm working it's been a series of
steps to realize just what the what the
what the parameters are and working with
that i'm still kind of
i've got a long-term some long-term
ideas and some short-term realities and
yeah it's kind of unclear all right
all that stuff you just said
is grade a
choice downtown houston bs okay you have
to go get a job
you have to get a job and it's not gonna
be your forever job it's gonna be
something that begins to slowly and i'm
talking micro steps inch by inch give
you purpose back
and it's not gonna be follow your dreams
bro none of that crap
it's gonna be i am contributing to my
household because i got three little
girls
and i have a thing that i get up and go
do every day right now dude you are
caught on a loop
of what did i do what's going to happen
where is this thing headed and it's
going nowhere you got to go somewhere
so i whether it's starbucks well i don't
care what it is you got to figure that
out but you got to get a job okay
then in two months five months six
months when your smoke clears on this
deal your divorce is finally settled
settled settled and you've moved to
spring you've got some sort of rhythm
then you can start saying okay what
comes next
and there's a million
people who work in ministry that get
laid off and go on to take those skills
the ones that you learned about empathy
putting on a performance every week in
front of hundreds if not thousands of
people how to um
listen how to love people who are
struggling dude companies will pay
handsomely for your skill set you're
just gonna have to work through that and
that will take time that's not for today
though today is i gotta go get a job i
gotta start doing a thing okay and stop
stewing in my head about it got your
word on that we go get a
job okay yeah okay anything i don't care
what you're making like you're anything
will be more than what you have right
now right
here's the big one
you had a picture when you got married
that you were not gonna be like mom and
dad am i right
yeah
yeah
and there's something catastrophic in
our souls when i swear
before god and all my friends and family
i will not be like you two and then you
look up 10 years later and you're
exactly like them if not worse
right
so here's the word you have to grieve
this
you got to sit in it with a journal and
write it out
it's gonna hurt like hell it's gonna be
hard it's gonna be painful
and there's a light on the other side of
that if you avoid this you will pass
this on to your three daughters and
they'll repeat this thing again
okay
here's what it starts with
dear sam
i thought things would be different and
so far they're not
period that's how your journal starts
here's the things i wanted to look
differently
here's the things that aren't different
and then as you're writing you're going
to start to incorporate here's what i'm
going to do about it
here's where things are going to be
different
and over time you're going to work with
a counselor and you're going to build
that and build that and build that
but slowly you're going to begin to let
your brain know sam's in charge for the
first time in my life how old are you
brother
32 32 i fell apart at 36 35 nah 30 35 34
35
okay
stone mad i took a 70 000 household
income pay cut went to move to a new
city with my wife and young kid to try
to figure things out
things worked out okay
all right
do you trust me on that
yeah okay
okay
little little little little little bitty
steps
if you lose your job the data tells us
that um it's as traumatic to your body
as
the death of a loved one
the trauma your body is screaming at you
we're not safe we're not safe we're not
safe you got to grieve that divorce
not safe not safe not safe it's trauma
your childhood trauma
your position right now terrified trauma
listen to me very carefully you're not
leaving those little girls are we on the
same page there
yes of course
are you gonna hurt yourself
um
no not not in potentially my my fear is
that i've i've never had ideation like
that and about three months ago that
happened for the first time yeah you're
tired
my guess is you don't want to be dead my
guess is you don't want to leave your
girls my guess is you want to stop
hurting right now is that fair
yeah yeah
i get that
do i have your commitment you're not
gonna hurt yourself
yeah yeah
say i promise i won't hurt myself
i promise all over her muscle
and i'm in it for the long haul
okay i'm going to repeat what i said to
you
you're addicted to stress chemicals
that's going to be a long-term play okay
you've got to commit to
peace and it's gonna feel crazy for a
while you're gonna have to say things
like nope when your mind starts spinning
things up when you're about to text your
wife back to start a fight when you're
about to get mad at your parents for
whatever it is you gotta stop
okay tell your people in your world that
you're doing this and let them call you
out cool
okay okay
and you're gonna grieve this thing and
grieve this thing do you have a
counselor you can talk to do you have
like male buddies in your life you can
reach out to
no i i didn't i've made very little i
i've not been good at making male
friends okay yeah and i i should just
say friends
yeah that's cool and hey
you got to own what happened to you
brother
you got to own it it happened
and then the here's the deal
you've spent your entire life trying to
edit old sentences from your childhood
from life from theologically all those
things
yes
those sentences have appeared at the end
you were abused you were traumatized you
were told god hates you if there even is
one right you were told your parents are
you told marriage looks like all that
stuff
it's a period at the end of those
sentences
and there's going to be a gap and that's
grief
and that's where that's where the
healing starts as after the forest fire
when the soil becomes as fertile as it
can possibly be
the smoke clears and the world is
raiding on you salmon houston
my new best buddy
what are you going to write next
all of this is what do you write next
okay
so
your commitment is you're going to find
somebody whether it's at a local church
whether it's a counselor you're gonna
reach out i've actually you know what
hang on the line i'm gonna give you
three months at to betterhelp.com
therapy there okay i'm gonna hook you up
with it
and it's all it's digital so you don't
even have to make an appointment or
arrangements for your girls you can tell
them to go sit in front of a screen
which i don't ever say that go sit in
front of a screen daddy's got needs to
talk to somebody on the computer
and you can reach out and have somebody
walk alongside you until you get your
bearings straight okay until you can
find a permanent therapist up there in
spring where you're moving
okay
and you you start with that journal
today
go to walmart and buy one for nine bucks
or five bucks or whatever it is buy a
spiral notebook for 99 cents i don't
care
but we start today i want you to hang on
the line i'm gonna give you that and i'm
also gonna give you a copy of my new
book own your past change your future
which is
that title's for you my brother right
now i'm with you every step of the way
here and i want you to call me back if
you ever need something do i have your
word on that
yes thank you i'll do that thank you all
right i want you to take a deep deep
breath as deep as you can and hold it
hold it one
two three now drop breathe it out
breathe all the way out and drop your
shoulders all the way down
today's the day it starts anew
okay
thank you doctor you're in
i'm in are you in yeah
yeah honey
awesome we'll be right back
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john de loni show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance or i can't get off work and
time to go see somebody it's way across
town what do i do because i want help
with my anxiety my depression my
relationships are hanging on by a thread
i want to be a better mom i gotta
process this trauma that happened to me
when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with better help because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john deloney show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
all right oh that was good we'll be
we're back let's go to uh kristen in
columbus ohio what's up kristen
hi john how are you i am
i was gonna say dancing on the ceiling
but
lionel richie owns that line so i'm just
hanging out here what's up
um so i'm calling because i have a
daughter who will be 18 on friday
congratulations and may the force be
with you
yes
and she suffers from pretty extreme
anxiety in all areas cool social
um
anxiety all of it yeah so
she's getting ready to graduate high
school
and go off to college in the fall and
she is going away to school away from
home
and i'm looking for some strategies the
best way to help her deal with the
anxiety as she transitions into this
next life phase i love it great
questions all right i'm gonna ask you a
few quick questions okay
sure um question number one
where did she
learn this
is there somebody in your home that
struggles with anxiety do you wrestle
with it where did she pick that up as a
coping skill her dad and i have
struggled with anxiety and depression
okay okay
um
what does it look like for her
when she's when she's spun out what is
that what does that look like
she will get very angry
very emotional
break out in tears
sometimes emotionally shut down it's
kind of a variety but it's usually an
extreme shutdown don't want to deal with
it or
yell lash out get angry cry okay kind of
those extremes where did she
how many of those behaviors are from
home too
and again this isn't an indictment i'm
just trying to get a full picture of of
her
oh no absolutely um
i cry pretty easily okay um
i cried at gas station commercials so
i'm with you
and there's been
a significant amount of yelling in the
home over the years okay all right
does she know have you and your husband
individually not together because that
can be overwhelming have the two of you
ever taken her out
and just said hey here's my story here's
my journey with anxiety with depression
yes how did that go
she
gets pretty defensive okay
and reacts more like you don't
understand what i'm going through okay
it's different from me she's 17. that's
right i mean yeah that's exactly yeah
yeah that's developmentally appropriate
response
hey i've been there too i've seen a cute
boy too you don't understand yeah okay
all right
so see your old half balding dad with
the rim like he used to be really
handsome back anyway but yeah that's
that's that's appropriate so um has your
husband done that
he has um
and again
i love him he's supportive he's an
all-in dad but we do approach it i think
very differently okay and
he
is more of a i'll talk to her
she'll get through it
i don't want to add to the stress by
calling out the behavior
so i don't want to say it's an avoidance
type of behavior but his is more of i'll
talk through it with her
and
give her my advice and then we'll see if
it changes
all right so
um you may have if you listen to the
show for any length of time you may have
heard me tell the story but i was doing
a practicum with a
child psychologist and
i had a young son and i was asking him
hey what what uh
what are some things i could tell my son
we had just dealt with a really messy
issue with the youngster and
the young kid said some really awful
things about women and he was like the
kid was four so clearly he'd picked this
up and i have i had a young son too and
so i was using this kid as a proxy for
my own kid and i said what are you
supposed to tell a kid to help him like
respect women and he said that dr gomez
smiled at me and he said
and you can tell them anything you want
they're not going to listen to you if
you want them to treat your wife right
um if you want him to respect women then
treat your wife right
because kids here's the magic quote kids
don't listen to you they watch you
and so you all can call out your
daughter's behaviors all day long
don't act like that i can't believe
you're throwing this temper tantrum you
don't talk like that to people in this
house you can do that all day long but
if the house is filled with chaos or
anxiety or yelling
that speaks that is the road map that
your daughter has been given to how to
handle stress and how to handle hard
things
and so
often when people say how do i deal with
the anxiety how my kids got anxiety what
what can i do for them i tell them fix
your marriage
and
that's usually where a lot of that stuff
starts not always there's there's
medical issues all kind of stuff but
you your your willingness to be honest
is really helpful here so let me fast
forward to i spent 20 years 17 years i
don't know how a long time almost two
decades working with college kids in
this exact world right
so
tell me about her academic success
she's almost a straight a student um
she i think she's gotten one a minus in
her four years of high school how dare
her
what a failure did she cry over it did
she weep
she's
no but she brings it up every so often
of i don't have a perfect record because
of this do you have other kids and
i have a son who's two years older
what is his
how are his grades
he's more of a b-plus student okay so
and his was
i'll do the best i can if it's not an a
i'm okay with it okay
a lot of he was more accepting a lot of
kids with anxiety
are performers
they have an a very attentive radar for
other people watching out for what
they're doing right and wrong
and either they are trying to
control other people's emotions in the
house because that's one of the jobs
they've been given for instance hey
don't say that dad's going to get really
mad
or you know your father doesn't like
whatever or mom loses her crap when this
happens so don't
and so kids feel like it's my job to
perform in whatever way so that mom and
dad
don't have to have their outbursts
and that
rattles a kid's body it makes kids
anxious makes adults anxious right when
they're responsible for their bosses or
for their spouse's behaviors right so
often straight a's and one of the
challenges with academics is straight
a's looks like my kid's successful
but really they have learned if i can do
this it avoids that
right
and often this is gonna sound bonkers
kids who get into drugs kids who get
into
sleeping around a lot kids who get into
straight a's
the behaviors are different but the
intent is the same
i need connection i need somebody to see
me
i need to avoid right they're all
avoidant if i get straight a's mom and
dad leave me alone so is her is that her
and again i'm using part of this to
teach to the audience too does that is
that her is straight a's keep y'all off
her back or is that where she finds
esteem or she just a really smart kid
who loves cranking it out
i think she's really smart and i think
that's where she finds her self-esteem
okay okay so she's got a picture of
success here okay so yeah
i'll give you some hard truths and some
reality truths is that cool
yes what is um give me a picture of her
college
uh
fancy pants private school fancy pants
state school like what is she is she
leaving the state where she going you
don't should tell me the name of the
school
no it's a four-year private school it's
a catholic university
and it's as far on the east
coast of ohio the east end of ohio she
can get without getting out of the state
um so she's doing a classic
seven-year-old running away which is i'm
running away all the way to the backyard
right okay
and um
she
again did get some pretty significant
scholarships for this particular school
okay um but
it yeah that's what it is it's a
catholic faith-based university about
two and a half hours from home okay
so
an anxious and
often not always but often depressed
brain is a in a child especially is a
disconnected brain
so if i'm sending my kid two hours away
i'm going to a make and she's got
clinically diagnosed anxiety clinically
diagnosed depression right this isn't
just she stresses out but she is this is
a challenge
a
for sure i'm gonna check with the
disability students disabilities office
make sure she's got the report the
support resources she needs i'm making
sure she's got somebody to call if
things get heavy
the second thing is
i am as a parent and this can be the
helicopter i don't care i will make sure
that she is at least plugged in with the
student counseling center now they can't
call you they can't tell you unless
she's suicidal which hopefully she never
gets there she can't they can't tell you
she's going to sessions they can't do
any of that stuff okay but
making sure there's a contact and when i
worked in in those positions i would get
emails from parents and i would forward
them on to the counseling center the
counseling center proactively reaches
out to the student so it is not weird or
odd or anything like that for parents to
reach out and say my kids struggled with
this forever i want to put them on your
radar on day one that's actually really
helpful for the school okay
even for the residence life program if
you want to have that conversation i
will tell you
picking a kid up from everything they
know and setting them in a brand new
environment is tough their brain is
going to say hey whoa we're super
disconnected now
and so
really encouraging her
really encouraging her to get plugged in
with student activities whether that's
with clubs and organizations or whatever
encourage encourage encourage even if
it's
you don't you've got to get involved in
two things here or i'm not sending any
more money for whatever right and that's
what i would do with my kids i would
make a financial incentive you have to
get plugged in with with
future
nursing association of america or the
future of medical students or future
engineers or whatever she's going to do
you got to get involved in that group or
my money stops because i know the
psychology you've got to get involved in
something
and here's the last one
no matter what
don't let her live by herself in a
private room especially the first year
especially she got to have a roommate
here's why
if you have a private room the only
reason to leave your room
is to leave the building
and there's not what i call accidental
community you have to run into people
who are using the bathroom who are
coming and going you have to learn to
manage that
and that person even if they're annoying
and they drive you crazy
that person becomes an anchor for you or
at least gives you something to talk
about to somebody else
but that person becomes a checkpoint hey
hey where were you last night in that
kind of
uh accountability that kind of hey
what's up hey how's it going what's up
and my i was a loudmouth brash
long-haired idiot who was into punk rock
and metal from houston and my roommate
was a
short
kind theater major from rural kansas
you could not have picked two more crazy
random people
and ultimately he was in my wedding and
i was in his and he is the guy who takes
care of my investments now out in
colorado spring so and him and i have he
came and stayed with me last year so all
i have to say is it's there's a lot of
decisions to be made as you as you move
into these relationships but
under no circumstances would i send a
kid who i know has clinical anxiety and
depression and say you should live by
yourself in a box two and a half hours
away and deal with the academic stress
and rigor alone
that's a recipe for disaster okay i
don't know she's self-aware enough that
she even said that she said i'd love to
have a private room but i know i need to
have a roommate beautiful beautiful
beautiful that's awesome
all right so here's the last thing i
want to recommend
i want you
to not talk about her anxiety or
depression
i want you to talk about
man you know i want you to take her out
and just have mom's breakfast mom's
lunch mom's dinner
and until she leaves i want you to make
once a week thing i've recommended this
to parents for years once a week you got
to come out for me for a meal i'll take
you to school or whatever you'll go to
school on your own i don't know whatever
it is saturday mornings whatever or our
time
and i'm going to tell you some things i
wish i had done differently and we're
going to talk about you mom
you know what i wish i hadn't yelled so
much in the house
i avoided my anxiety for a long time i
wish i hadn't done that
i'm sorry
like i'm really working on my yelling
and i'm actually starting to see a
counselor now i don't know if i don't
know if i told you that but i'm trying
to do that now
i want you to spend some time talking
about you telling stories about when you
were in college when you were young when
you had kids when you were scared and
all those things
here's what it's going to do it's going
to humanize your journey we call it
social norming she's going to realize
she's not crazy
that her
experiences other people have had them
and she's going to build a connection
with you in a relationship with you that
hopefully will translate into a once a
week you'll write a letter when she's in
college you will connect with her in
college etc you'll keep this line open
not an everyday texting mom about
everything line but a communication line
so she's gonna be way out there but
she's gonna have an anchor point at home
and it's not an anchor point on you
better get your crep it's an anchor
point on i love you and i've been there
too
very few things heal an anxious heart
like
i love you i'm with you and i've been
there too thank you so much for the call
we'll be right back
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you got an expert in a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 in mls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right let's take unimas let's go out
to new hampshire talk to caroline what's
up caroline
oh not much how are you doctor john we
are just rocking onto the brick of dawn
how can it help
um so my question for you is how do i
deal with adversity
as an adult
if i didn't deal with it as a child or
young adult
are you comparing your adversity
uh probably
where did you learn that
uh i think it was self-taught
oh what a great job you should have gone
to you should have taken lessons
um
so
are you facing adversity now are you
just worried about it's gonna come and
you think you're not gonna be prepared
for it
um worry it's gonna come you know
like
kind of waiting for like a shoe to drop
kind of thing maybe
where'd you learn that
um i don't know i'm kind of a
perfectionist people pleaser maybe that
it comes from that where'd you learn
that
um
probably my childhood
what what um who did you need to keep
happy in your childhood
my father
why he's like very type a
um
very
maybe a little angry sometimes
very demanding
kind of walked on eggshells a little bit
ah and as a young girl you learned a
very important lesson which was
it's your job
as a seven-year-old to make sure dad
doesn't get angry
yeah and you have that power as a
seven-year-old to decide whether or not
a grown man
loses his crap or not
there's a there's a word for that and
it's called trauma
okay
so
you have experienced adversity i
guarantee it okay
a lot i just
i just feel like i probably just compare
it to other people you do and so i feel
like it's little t into the big t and so
let me have you heard my analogy about
the bricks in the backpack
yes okay so
let's say your dad had been a dad who
just closed fist hit you as a kid
those are bricks those are cinder blocks
right
you go to school and you're hiding
bruises did that ever happen to you
uh no okay never
or
you come home every day and your dad
says stand up and you stand up and he
says that skirt is too short i told you
to go change your clothes now
not hi how are you baby how was your day
then he says bring me your bring your
homework folder now
and you bring it to him and he says 98
what happened
why
well i missed two we went over this when
you and i studied like right
what that is is little t that's a pebble
that in your backpack over and over and
over and by the time you're 25
the weight of that backpack is the same
okay okay
so
the key to coming overcoming adversity
is being able to stand firm on two feet
that my space counts my voice counts the
way i feel about this counts and i'm not
right about everything also both and
do you feel that
most people with crazy angry fathers are
always waiting for the next shoe to drop
because i can have my feet propped up
and got all my stuff done for the day
it's a good day
but at any moment that car is gonna
drive
up is that is that ring a bell
um yeah not so like
not so much the skirt is future in like
lemon tear grays i think it was like
like he wasn't happy with meals or
something like yeah i mean those are all
plug and play i'm just making those
things up okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
you insert your own childhood into that
right
um and
i and i'm just painting a caricature
here but yes at the end of the day
most of us who have angry dads will go
around the rest of our life looking over
our shoulders waiting for the next thing
to happen
right or what what's the thing i'm gonna
do for other people and what i want you
to know is other people are responsible
for their responses you are not you are
responsible for caroline that's your job
right
and so
i think when it comes to adversity if
you are now you said you're standing on
two feet how'd you learn that
time i think just going through like
just
um having to build my career and i just
bought a house got married so i've been
definitely
growing up i guess did you marry your
dad
or is your husband a nice guy
he's
opposite
yeah
good for you
good for you so let me tell you
never
ever ever ever
compare your adversity never compare
your trauma never compare your grief
those are yours
and if you sat with a counselor for a
while they'd probably unpack some stuff
that you don't even want to talk about
anymore
and they
probably you could have some
conversations with me off air about some
things in your childhood that you've not
told a lot of people is that fair
oh yeah yeah so i haven't been i have
been being counselor good for you look
at you caroline
come what may dude caroline's gonna
man you're all you're strong you're
strong right yeah my my counselor last
week actually like gave it to me
straight and was like the one's gonna be
enough like when you have heart disease
or like die like one is gonna be enough
i was like oh okay
hey
right on nailed it nailed it nailed it
nailed it okay you are strong
you're strong
and what i want to tell you is you got
to let your body off the hook
because it's working really hard to
defend yourself from punches that aren't
coming
and the ones that do come you'll never
see them
and you will get them they'll come
they'll come out of nowhere you'll get
fired somebody will pass away somebody
will whatever that's life all of us have
that
two key things number one stand strong
you know that continued growth continue
counseling continue
really
doubling down on making sure your
marriage is strong
and the second thing is have friends in
your life
other people are your emergency fund for
life
right and we get obsessed with this
adversity this resilience i can do it
all my own you can you gotta have other
people in addition to your husband he
can't be everything you gotta have
people that you call at three a.m when
you're scared you gotta have people that
say hey i'm waiting for this shoe to
drop am i right and they'll go no dong
let's go out you got to have those
people in your life so do the hard work
to make sure you're surrounded by people
who love you and that could be weird or
awkward or all those things make sure it
happens because caroline my sister
and new best buddy
you're worth it we'll be right back
big secret almost all of us can control
our thoughts
yes you can control your thoughts you
choose them most people believe thoughts
randomly happen and that we have to give
rent-free space to bad thoughts and
scary thoughts and freaky thoughts this
is not true
our world doesn't want you to know this
because they want the privilege of
owning your mind no more i want to teach
you how to take back your thoughts
if you often find yourself lost in a
tornado of toxic thoughts and anxiety
and always on high alert you'll have to
be intentional about changing your
thoughts but it is 100
possible
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to mental health
and wellness that includes learning how
to reject harmful thoughts and cultivate
thoughts that move you closer to who you
want to be so go to johndaloni.com to
take the next step towards wellness
that's own your past change your future
at johndaloni.com
all right as we wrap up today's show um
ben just told me that i used the phrase
best buddies twice today in the show
so it sounds like we have a death match
that needs to happen between uh the
original call and caroline i'll let them
set that up on the internets
pay-per-view 5.95 go to go to
kellydaniel.com and she'll have it for
you all right today's song is times like
these by the one and only foo fighters
dave grohl and the gang and it goes like
this
i am a one-way motorway i'm the one that
drives away follows you back home i'm a
street light shining i'm a white light
blinding bright burning off and on
uh-huh
times like these you learn to live again
it's times like these you give and give
again it's times like these you learn to
love again it's times like these
time and time again i'll see you soon
take care